[موسيقى]
ان شعبا يرزح تحت الاحتلال والهيمنه له
الحق في المقاومه بكل الوسائل تعتبر دوله
اسرائيل اليوم ومنذ احتلال عام
1967 وقبل ذلك دوله خارجه على القانون
ويتم التسامح معها باعتبارها فوق القانون
قاطع عشان غزه قاطع عشان غزه قاطع عشان
غزه قطع عشان
غز
[موسيقى]
فس اسرائيل حركه مقاطعه اسرائيل وسحب
الاستثمارات منها وفرض العقوبات عليها
المعروفه عالميا باسم بي دي اس اطلقت في
2005 من قبل الغالبيه الساحقه في المجتمع
الفلسطيني بعد اعوام طويله من انتظار
ما يسمى بالمجتمع الدولي لذلك قررنا المضي
في طريق جنوب افريقيا وهو مقاومه داخليه
مع حركه تضامن عالميه قويه تعزل هذا
النظام تماما والشركات والمؤسسات المتورطه
فيه هكذا تعمل حركه المقاطعه مع الشركات
لا نتحدث معهم عن الاخلاق والقانون الدولي
والحقوق الانسان الشركات لا تفهم هذه
اللغه تفهم لغه المال
والارباح
[موسيقى]
نظام اسرائيل الاحتلالي والاستعماري
والعنصري لا يقوم على قوه اسرائيل وحدها
يقوم على مجموعه علاقات دبلوماسيه وسياسيه
واقتصاديه واكاديميه وفنيه وثقافيه
ورياضيه بدونها لا لا يستطيع هذا النظام
ان
[موسيقى]
يستمر في شبه القاره الهنديه قامت حركه
عماليه تمثل 30 مليون شخص بالانضمام الى
بيدي اس من خلال مكاتب اتحادهم
العمال ملايين ملايين من الناس تدرك الان
ما هي حركه بيدي اس والمبادئ
القائمه اي خطر تمثله بالفعل حركه
المقاطعه بيدي اس هنالك هستيريا كبيره
هنالك قلق بالغ من هذه الحركه لماذا
لانها نوع جديد من النضال ضد اسرائيل لانه
في حقيقه الامر هي تشير وتؤشر الى المشكله
الحقيقيه المتمثله بالاجرام المستمر ضد
القانون
[موسيقى]
الدولي
هل سيرحل سائر الشعب الفلسطيني لا لن
يرحلوا وسيحمل المفتاح على مر الزمن مفتاح
موطنهم وثقافتهم وانسانيتهم ولن يتنازلوا
عنه ابدا ولا ينبغي لهم ان يتنازلوا ويمرر
لاولئك المشتغلين في حركه بي بي اس ونحن
لن نتخلى عنه على
الاطلاق
با رايل با
[موسيقى]
اسرايل